oolitic limestone blocks used to build
the Pentagon and Empire State Building
were made by microbes that lived up to
340 million years ago so thanks for the
building materials microbes and a study
of ethnic groups on the Malay Peninsula
found that hunter-gatherers are far more
adept at identifying smells than farmers
the szymek berry were able to name
specific smells as easily as we name
colors which suggests that how we live
affects how we smell Vsauce Kevin here
this is mind blow
[Music]
NASA is working to ensure that planes
avoid one another's wake and even figure
out how to surf them with about 100,000
flights per day worldwide sophisticated
air traffic control systems make sure
planes don't collide but a wake
encounter can be just as dangerous the
automated cooperative trajectories
project at NASA's Armstrong Flight
Research Center are using technology to
track invisible spinning wakes described
as horizontal tornadoes and they're
inspired by concepts in nature such as
when geese fly in a V formation planes
that fly on top of rising air from wicks
will be able to conserve fuel and reduce
emissions which is good it turns out
babbling babies manipulate adults and it
helps them further their own education
researchers at Cornell's behavioral
analysis of beginning years laboratory
or baby lab found that babies organize
their mother's verbal responses and use
more mature babbling to draw out more
interactions that results in a greater
number of learning opportunities for
babies and encourages simpler responses
and learn about information so babble
blablabla actually means teach me more
speaking of babies dolphins recognize
themselves in a mirror and they can do
it many months sooner than human babies
a psychologist at Hunter College spent
years working with two dolphins Bayley
and foster observing their behavior in a
mirror she found that by seven months
dolphins engaged in self-directed
behavior including wagging their tongues
and swirling their bodies in contrast
human babies take 12 to 15 months to
reach this developmental milestone so
score one for dolphins electronic skin
that lets you manipulate virtual objects
is poised to replace bulky VR wearables
researchers from Germany have combined
two existing technologies to develop a
barely perceptible electronic skin that
uses magnetic fields to track movement
and the next step is to ditch permanent
magnets and incorporate the use of
geomagnetic fields for positioning the
way that sharks can which sounds amazing
and now a word from ants co when the
neighbors drop by for a slideshow
it's fun for everyone but what's the
answer when you want to run off both
regular-sized slides and oversized
slides the answer is the new and
schematic the A+ slide projector from
Ensco it's the world's only fully
automatic projector to take all popular
slides cardboard glass metal and plastic
and when it's time for those big two and
a quarter slides no problem and
schematic project some clear and sharp
and an schematic runs itself or with the
remote control you can control your
slides from anywhere in the room at any
speed you choose at the end of the show
and schematic even turns on the lights
the new end schematic is available at
most dealers for just 1195 down
photographs projected in your living
room awesome let's do a blowback mind
blow 99 in November 2015 featured the
scanned pyramids project and they just
recently discovered two mysterious voids
the voids in the Great Pyramid of Giza
will be inspected by a mix of subatomic
particle detection and tiny robots built
over 4,500 years ago the Great Pyramid
is the oldest wonder of the world but
it's difficult to study without damaging
small particles called muons form when
cosmic rays interact with the Earth's
atmosphere and they lose speed when they
travel through dense objects by
measuring muon velocity they identified
two secret chambers that could be
corridors serve structural functions or
who knows a team from the French
National Institute for computer science
and applied mathematics is also
constructing two very small robots that
will be able to explore the voids by
entering through a tiny drilled hole a
team of Canadian paleontologists have
shed light on why few modern animals
have the tail weaponry that made some
dinosaurs so destructive
they concluded that animals with tail
weapons like the ankylosaurus were
generally large herbivorous and had
armored bodies as skin armor evolved
from bone tail weapons evolved to be
softer to modern animals like porcupines
tend to have tail weapons made of the
softer keratin except for smog a small
lizard named after the dragon in the
hobbit that
Taine's a boney spiked tail presumably
to guard treasure the coyote 3 initially
designed for space exploration is now
being used for searching rescue and to
identify gas leaks in buildings the
German Research Center for artificial
intelligence developed the coyote and
proved that it was capable of handling
any kind of terrain its onboard computer
allows autonomous exploration and
responding to data from sensors for
practical purposes here on earth yet
another trickle-down benefit from space
research roosters are really loud why
don't they go deaf roosters have evolved
to protect themselves from their own
deafening crows researchers at the
University of Antwerp and University of
Kent found that the internal sound
pressure of a roosters crow can reach a
whopping 140 decibels which is 50
decibels more than a lawnmower and 20
more than a loud concert micro CT scans
of roosters heads showed that their
auditory canal closes when their beak
opens which essentially plugs their own
ears and insulates them from damage now
you know that the brains of musicians
may be as different as the music they
play researchers from the Max Planck
Institute for human cognitive and brain
sciences in Leipzig found that different
processes occur in the brains of
classical and jazz musicians even when
they played the same exact piece the
study of professional penis showed that
jazz musicians were more flexible and
able to replan harmonies more easily
than classical pianists suggesting that
evaluating the effects of music on the
brain might be most accurate when done
across the global musical spectrum the
European Union seconds hands project is
supporting the development of robots
with predictive action to help humans
mr6 as a human-like robot that can aid
maintenance technicians by recognizing
what they're doing they offer help at
the perfect time one of the things we're
working on now is a project called
second hands this is developing
want to assist our maintenance
technicians and it's called second hands
because it's literally meant to be a
second pair of hands for the technician
to get their work done having now
received the second hands robot in our
lab at Accardo we're working together
with all the partners to integrate all
the different functionalities in order
to demonstrate a real-world maintenance
task I've been editing mind blow using
premiere for years now and if you're
interested in learning how to edit check
out learn Adobe Premiere in one hour
over at skill share like all their
courses it's taught by an expert so you
get top-notch information from people
who know what they're talking about and
for a limited time get your first 3
months for just 99 cents this is a
special deal I worked with Ethan from
Skillshare on just for fans of mind blow
and if you don't have 99 cents you can
get free mini lessons if you subscribe
to their YouTube channel so click the
links at the top of this video's
description because whether you're
looking for premium courses or free
insights you can learn a lot with skill
share now I'm gonna leave you with a
force multiplying robot with remote
operation for sensitive and dangerous
tasks because I know you want that and
as always thanks for watching
[Music]
the domestication of the computer
already has begun in Phoenix Arizona the
Charles cross Shaw family has learned to
live with a computer terminal in their
kitchen this teletypewriter is connected
by ordinary telephone lines to a
computer complex in New York City 2400
miles away
Charles cross saw a General Electric
engineer works on technical problems his
wife Barbara uses the computer for
various household chores here the
computer has expanded the proportions of
a recipe for sex into a recipe for
fourteen are the 21st century home
computers may be as common as today's
telephone what are you doing the
children of the 21st century might be
educated by a computer at home across
your daughter's do some of their
homework this way today tomorrow's home
computer won't simply do old jobs and
new ways by the time the Crawshaw
daughters have families of their own we
may have created jobs for computers that
we haven't even dreamed of today even
with a computer in her kitchen mrs.
cross still cooks her family's meals
cooking might be different in the 21st
century industrial designer Henry
Dreyfuss I like to think that the art of
baking a homemade pie won't be lost but
maybe the one that comes out of the
supermarket's gonna be better than the
way that you can make at home it was
brief applause the art I think that
packages for quick food and this doesn't
just have to be in the kitchen the
package might very well have a a
disposable electric plug as part of it
and you just plug this in the package
would heat you eat the food and you
might even need to package all of wasted
paper in the world it's conceivable that
when the package was heated it returned
into part of the food
[Music]
[Music]